can you hear me
all right thank you very much
hey good afternoon everyone welcome and
thank you for coming out on this hot and
sunny day uh I'd like to like welcome
everyone who's here for the ceremony
this afternoon my name is Kathy mikas
I'm a 10-year volunteer with Mom's
demand action for gun sense in America
our purpose our goal the reason we exist
is to bring an end to gun violence in
our country
today is National Gun Violence Awareness
Day
it's a it's a day that is when We Gather
to support people whose lives have been
impacted by gun violence
and to commit all of us every one of us
to making the changes that are needed to
end the tide of gun violence in our
country
we are going to be hearing from people
whose lives have been directly impacted
by gun violence and um they are powerful
speakers
so now it's my honor to introduce our
first Speaker my friend Holland home
Holland is a survivor of the 1997 mass
shooting at Paducah Heath High School
he's a graduate of Western Kentucky
University and the University of
Louisville's School Brandeis School of
Law I tripped over that every time sorry
he resides in Old Louisville with his
wife and his two children his wife's
here today and he Holland is in every
town
every town Survivor fellow and he is a
spokesperson for Mom's demand action
please join me in welcoming my friend
Holland home
[Applause]
thank you so much for the introduction
on December 1st 1997 gun violence
changed my life and I live with those
changes to this day
it was the Monday after Thanksgiving and
I was a freshman in high school
we had just finished our morning prayer
group and I was heading to Spanish class
through the lobby when I heard a series
of Pops like balloons bursting
I heard two maybe three and then
everything went black
a student who I had known since the
third grade lunch table had reached into
his backpack pulled out a handgun and
opened fired in the crowded Lobby
in the aftermath of that act of violence
three girls died Nicole Hadley Jessica
James and Casey Steger and four other
students other than myself were wounded
some with lifelong injuries that they
still struggle with
I had been shot in the head and while
the doctors were able to close that
wound with about a dozen Staples
I don't know if I would be here today if
that bullet had been a little further to
the right or been fired from the barrel
of an AR-15 style assault rifle
25 years later in addition to the
physical scar that I hide in my hairline
I carry with me the mental scars of the
fear and the anguish and the memories of
the aftermath
to this very day
I relive that day again and again and
again whenever I hear the news of
another school shooting
and my heart aches for the people in the
city impacted by gun violence each and
every day
I speak out now about what happened to
me because it shouldn't be happening
we can end gun violence and that's why
it's important that we're all here today
raising awareness and keeping the fight
against gun violence going
we can stop the tragic gun violence that
happens to our neighbors and our loved
ones each and every day
in this city and in Forever impacts
their friends and family like Krista
Gwynn who all who will share her story
next
we can stop mass shootings like the one
that tragically killed wounded and
traumatized louisvillians in April
we can stop school we can stop school
children in this city from having to go
on lockdown in their classrooms because
of a mass murder at the bank down the
street
we can stop making our children live in
fear and prevent childhood trauma
this is not inevitable or something we
should accept as normal it's not normal
Tyree Smith a 16 year old JCPS student
died by gun violence at the school at a
school bus stop in our city
I recently witnessed a child at my kids
own bus stop instinctively hide behind a
car because a heavy truck made a loud
bang as it passed us
what are we doing to our children
we owe it to them to solve this problem
we owe it to the families in the city
who have carried the scars and loss of
gun violence across Generations
in Kentucky guns are the leading cause
of death for children and teens
not car accidents not coveted guns
so what's the solution
first I can tell you what's not the
solution
we don't solve a gun violence crisis by
making it illegal for state and local
police to cooperate with Federal Gun
crimes investigations
our state legislature did that this year
we don't saw the gun violence crisis by
allowing students and members of the
public to bring more guns on school
campuses
our legislature tried to do that this
year
the solution to the problem is never
more of the problem
instead Frankfurt must allow Louisville
to address our local gun problem with
local solutions by local leaders who are
accountable to local voters
Frankfurt must treat gun violence like
the Public Health crisis it is and vote
to establish the office of safer
communities so we can understand the why
of the crisis and then work together on
the how of solving it
and you can help
reach out to your Metro council member
and urge them to support more local
funding of the office of safe and
healthy neighborhoods which seats seeks
systemic solutions to this systemic
problem of gun violence
60 percent of Ocean's funding comes from
federal covet emergency funds which will
expire in two years
Metro counseling Metro council is
looking at the work of ocean is doing
right now and needs to start planning
right now to fund that at the local
level for the future
gun violence costs Kentucky
9.6 billion dollars annually that
amounts to two thousand dollars for each
Kentuckian
any dollars we invest in preventing gun
violence will help us avoid the cost of
the aftermath
and avoid the incalculable human toll
we must improve background checks we
must close the Gun Show loophole and we
must pass legislation enabling extreme
risk protection orders
[Applause]
we can do this we can end gun violence
in our city
and in our state if we have the courage
to try
please join us today as we focus on gun
violence gun violence survivors and
bring awareness to this Public Health
crisis thank you
[Applause]
my story of gun violence is shocking
because of where it happened but there
are so many stories out there that shock
because of their repetition and their
frequency
we have many in our community who have
seen gun violence in a generational
cycle
and our next speaker is Krista gwin she
is a mom in Louisville and like far far
too many parents in this city has had a
child taken from her by gun violence
her son Christian or Chris was 19 when
he died and then two years later Chris's
daughter was almost taken from her by a
gun also at age 19.
Krista thank you for joining us today
and sharing your story
[Applause]
no
I'm Krista Gwen standing here with my
husband Nevada Gwen and my 15 year old
Nevada going
yes same name
if it's good once it's good twice
we are here today on one common ground
we have had gun violence and some kind
of shape and form affect our lives
gun violence has affected us on 1219
2019 our son Christian was shot and
killed walking home on 43rd and Market
by a drive-by shooter he was three weeks
into being 19 years old
our son was a good kid always respected
his parents and was a hard-working young
man
to lose his life on a date on a day off
of work just trying to enjoy the day
it's a horrible thing
a year and six months later June the 7th
2021 this Wednesday coming up matter of
effect will be two years my daughter
Victoria was shot and wounded
at a public park where she sat with her
friends which one of them was day one
coward
who lost his life my daughter was 19
three weeks until her 19th birthday
day one was 17.
my daughter was in the park the park was
unloaded upon with at least 300 rounds
of bullets my daughter compared the
sound of the bullets coming past her as
if she was in a war zone
still to this day she could not go out
in public
or partaking public festivities
because it's too hard of the sounds she
hear the car is going down the street
and the noise fireworks make on 4th of
July
today we come together to remember the
ones that we have lost
and to show love and support to the ones
who have survived this horrific ordeal
to bring awareness to the pandemic that
is plaguing our youth
this is something no one can do alone
this is something a community of
togetherness need to work on
we have one goal and that is to rid our
streets of such heinous activities
this is so there are so many groups here
today
that is trying to get a handle on this
but let me say this
we can get a in front of this
if we can join United in the situation
we have to work on one Accord that's
with the police government leaders to
stop losing our children to violence we
cannot expect the police to show up and
know what's going on
we have to show up and tell them
what's going on in our community
give them the homework they need to
solve the crimes
to get our neighborhood our schools and
our Parks safe again
to help our children get the tools in
school to better themselves
to turn our neighborhoods back into a
family that watches out for each other
gun violence is affecting all
nationalities not what not it doesn't
matter what color sex or preference you
are
you are not in this you are not in this
alone it does not just affect the poor
end of the neighborhood this is a global
thing and it's taking our kids by storm
my husband and I have lost the son
and have a daughter that is fighting for
survival every day mentally from losing
her brother to being shot and wounded
into losing her best friend
I don't want another family to have to
stand here and say that about their
family
we should not be bury me in our future
our children should not be scared to sit
out on the porch and enjoy a day
we should not duck and hide when a car
rides by and it's loud and pop
but we do
and that's a shame
our community is not speaking together
and not coming together
they want answers
they want Solutions but don't want to
help with the problem
I thank you for your time today and
thank you for your support and love
I now turn it over to the Louisville's
mayor Craig Greenberg who since took
office has hit the street fighting this
problem he has hit the street fight in
this problem since the day I met him
and I appreciate all he is trying to
change
for always listening when we call and
always there in a time of need
thank you
[Applause]
thank you so much Krista and to the Gwen
family
to Holland to Kathy thank you it's to to
Holland to Krista for sharing your
stories
to Holly
excuse me to Kathy and everyone from
Mom's demand action thank you all so
much to being out to being with us today
to my good friend Lonnie Ali thank you
for joining us in this incredibly
important cause
we can and will make change together
I want to especially thank Krista and
Holland for sharing their stories and
perspectives with all of us
they or who we need to listen to
they help us try to create wisdom and
understanding
out of moments of tragedy and Terror
there are far too many people in our
city and in our country
who've had these same moments that they
shared with you here today
when they feared for their own lives
when they feared for the lives of people
who they loved
or even lost people who they loved
I've had one of those moments myself
and I know that I'm one of the fortunate
ones
many people in Louisville too many
people in America
aren't as lucky as I was
and so many people should not have to
depend on luck in America in 2023 to
survive
we should not
[Applause]
we should not have to hope
that today isn't the day that a gunshot
claims our lives or takes someone we
love who was on the sidewalk or in a
park
or at a party
or at the mall
or at their home
or at work
we should not have to explain to young
children that it might be necessary for
them to hide under their desks if
someone comes into their school with a
gun to harm them or try to take their
life
but we do
over and over we do
and we're tired of it we're just tired
of the fear
and the losses and the excuses for why
we can't do more why we can't do
anything we're tired of those excuses
we're tired of hearing why we can't
really protect ourselves and our
children because that's simply not true
life doesn't have to be this way
this doesn't have to happen
February 14th 2022.
when a gunman walked into my office and
fired six gunshots at me
that doesn't have to happen
April 10th 2023 when a murderer killed
five co-workers at Old National Bank
that doesn't have to happen
April 15 2023
when two individuals were killed in an
evening at Chickasaw Park
that doesn't have to happen
this week at the Mall St Matthews when
gunfire opened out after an oral
argument began
that doesn't have to happen
and hundreds of other times before then
and since then
that are going to come in the future
that doesn't have to happen this gun
violence does not have to happen we can
prevent people from dying from suffering
from living in fear
there are so many things that we can do
this is there's not a magic answer
not one solution
but doing nothing clearly hasn't worked
so all of us here today and others
across the city I invite you invite you
to join us because we are taking action
to reduce gun violence we are trying to
do all we can do we're investing in our
neighborhoods and in people who have
been overlooked for Generations so every
child has an opportunity to succeed and
pursue their hopes and genes we're going
to invest more in mental health care
we're working to make early learning for
every child a reality here in Louisville
we're investing in Workforce Development
initiatives so everyone can have
training to have a good paying career
path job these are all important parts
of the solution
these will all save lives in the long
run
but let's be clear about something else
as important as these steps are as
important as this is for the long-term
solution we are absolutely kidding
ourselves if we don't talk about guns we
are kidding ourselves
we are kidding ourselves if we think we
can protect ourselves our children our
neighborhoods from gun violence if we
don't talk about guns if we don't do the
hard complicated and absolutely
necessary work of reducing the number of
guns that cause murder after murder in
our city and in our country we need
fewer guns on the street that are in the
wrong hands and are being used for the
wrong reason
and to do that
we need help from our friends in
Frankfurt
right now I'm already talking with
members of the Kentucky General Assembly
and what I'm asking them for is two
general things
first
if you support our police officers like
those who heroically ran into a barrage
of fire from awaiting assailant with an
assault weapon at Old National Bank on
April 10th
if you support local decision making to
address local issues
if you want to help our state's largest
city Thrive please
give us the autonomy here in Louisville
to deal with our unique gun violence
epidemic as we know how to deal with it
let us the people of Louisville who are
here today and around the entire city
make our own choices about how we reduce
gun violence in our own City
and second
and there'll be many more but second for
now
under current Kentucky law
the assault rifle that was used to
murder five of our neighbors at Old
National Bank
May one day be eventually auctioned off
think about that
this murder weapon and other murder
weapons returned to the streets under
Kentucky's current law
my Administration has already taken
action to remove the firing pins before
turning over confiscated weapons to the
state
because that's all the current law
allows us to do
that that's not enough
it's time to change this law let us
destroy illegal guns and the guns that
have been used to kill so they are never
used to commit harm again
I know every member of the state
legislature like everyone else in our
city and state and in the country is
horrified by the lives we're losing in
mass shootings and in any shooting
none of us wants this to happen again
but it will keep happening and that's
why we have to do more let's change the
state law that would make me as mayor a
criminal for trying too hard to stop the
actual criminals who are taking other
people's lives
the law the laws we have now are
enabling violence and murder
so let's work together to change these
laws so we can keep our people safe
especially our children
I'm cautiously optimistic
with conversations with my Democrat
friends and my Republican friends in
Frankfurt that we will all work together
to make meaningful changes
Krista Gwynn knows all too well the
unimaginable pain of losing a child
no parent should ever know or feel that
but far too many do
that's why we need the help of everyone
why we need others to join us here today
why we need Gatherings like this and why
we need leaders like Kathy makis and
organizations like Mom Mom's demand
action
Kathy and Mom's demand action have been
an outstanding partner and Advocate and
we're going to be working hard together
to push for change
they helped organize this event as part
of National Gun Violence Awareness Day
this day has a very special origin
its origin starts in Chicago
with Haiti of Pendleton
who marched with her school in President
Obama's second inaugural parade
not long after
she was shot and killed in Chicago
hideous friends and family asked
everyone to wear orange for hedia
because orange is bright like she was
orange is also the color that Hunters
wear to protect themselves from gunshots
in the woods
and Haiti's parents as people in Chicago
and around the country
to remember her and all victims of gun
violence on June 2nd
and not in memory of her and her
birthday
and so that's why so many of us are
wearing orange here today
I'm wearing the brightest orange shirt I
could find because I want my words my
administrative's actions and my clothes
to be as loud and as clear as possible
that's why
that's why tonight
working with Waterfront Park we are
lighting the big four Bridge orange
because we want to save that same
message
so please let's all work together to
change our laws and protect our children
we can and we will save lives by working
together thank you all very much
[Applause]
well first I want to say thank you mayor
Greenberg for everything you've done and
for everything you've committed to do
thank you for announcing that this is
gun violence awareness day thank you for
bringing so much attention to the issue
I'd encourage everyone to join the mayor
at the big four bridge to come to our
event tomorrow at Chickasaw park at 1 30
2 o'clock in the and uh to remember the
people who that were shot in the nation
and there are other groups that are also
holding events but I don't have a
complete list I think if you Google
where orange you can find it
all right so mayor Greenberg thank you
we're proud of what you're doing proud
of what you've done and proud to stand
with you thank you very much
[Applause]